eu sempre achei que para mudar o mundo
devido à minha formação em relações
internacionais
eu deveria viajar pelo globo todo mas eu
fui perceber que essa mudança pode comer
começará a partir da minha rua e do meu
bairro
durante a minha graduação com muita luta
sem dinheiro mas com muita determinação
eu conseguir ter alguma experiência a
nível internacional
então botei a mochila nas costas e eu
resisti por duas vezes nos estados
unidos
reside também na suíça portugal e china
tudo isso durante a graduação e foi o
meu primeiro contato com a imigração
porque o que nos estados unidos eu fiz
um programa de trabalho e estudo
e lá todos nós sabemos do fluxo
migratório de pai de latino-americanos
para aquele país
então eu fui perceber que existem
diferentes escalas de imigrantes nos
estados unidos o brasileiro praticamente
não é visto como latino e um mexicano
que trabalha na cozinha dos restaurantes
dos bares
ele é mais discriminado nesse nível
hierárquico do que o brasileiro eo
diferencial vem o intercambista porque o
intercambista tem prazo de validade ele
tem um tempo pra ficar e para retornar
ao seu país e tem outra estrutura
e lá eu trabalhei no restaurante como
garçom e eu tive algumas experiências
que não foram muito agradáveis nesse
sentido
no geral foi um dos melhores anos da
minha vida só que eu tive que ouvir
piadinhas enquanto servia às mesas como
de que país da américa latina a sua mãe
passou com você no colo a fronteira dos
estados unidos e até explicar que a
situação não era aquela a gente sabe o
que acontece
eu também tive que ouvir coisas como
esses brasileiros ilegais que vem pros
estados unidos roubar os nossos empregos
e essa situação
então ela também acabou se repetindo em
portugal
em portugal eu ganhei uma bolsa de
estudos onde eu não precisava pagar a
universidade aqui e não pagava
universidade lá também só que eu
precisava me manter e eu tinha colocado
como uma meta junto com a minha namorada
e nós vamos fazer um mochilão ao final
do programa
então eu arranjei o famoso pico o
emprego de quatro horas diárias onde
vendia internet televisão e telefone por
linha direta ligava os portugueses e
oferecia esse plano para eles então
vocês não têm noção de alguns absurdos
que eu escutei somente pelo fato de ser
brasileiro
outra situação quando nós fomos alugar
um apartamento eu combinei que
moraríamos eu a minha namorada e mais
duas amigas elas foram até a corretora
de imóveis que ela pensava que elas
seriam garotas de programas e que elas
não seriam intercambistas
então eu tive que estar junto e ouvir
dela o papa então este programa existe
mesmo e eu tentando imitar o sotaque
português porque eu pensava que as três
raparigas eram garotas de programa mas
eu quero ressaltar aqui que isso não é o
senso comum não é geral
são algumas experiências que foram me
colocar nessa situação têm esse contato
de ser um jovem imigrante em outro país
bom agora eu vou entrar no assunto que é
o terremoto que acontece no haiti em
2010 de acordo com as nações unidas
este terremoto deixou mais de 300 mil
mortos e um milhão e meio de desalojados
o tema o terremoto ele vem afeta toda a
infraestrutura do país inclusive o
palácio do governo que é destruído e
debilitada toda a a estrutura a nível de
social econômica e política e o que
acontece nessa nesse país que já era um
dos mais pobres do mundo e o mais pobre
do continente americano
um novo fluxo migratório pós-terremoto e
esse fluxo migratório são os haitianos
começam a vir para o brasil e esse fluxo
começa no ano de 2011 em 2011
balneário camboriú cidade aqui do
litoral norte na qual o resíduo começa a
receber os o primeiro grupo de 200
haitianos que vem para trabalhar na
empresa de limpeza urbana
eles chegam e encontra uma situação de
estabilidade econômica e pleno emprego
coisa que eles não tinham no haiti em
2013 é fundada a associação dos
haitianos de balneário camboriú
nesse mesmo ano eu deixo o meu trabalho
que é numa numa multinacional e aceita a
proposta de um vereador de primeira
eleição em primeiro mandato para chefiar
o gabinete dele porque eu acreditava e
eu poderia desenvolver tudo aquilo que
eu acreditava nível de política pública
tanto de juventude e essa aproximação
com os jovens imigrantes que vêm para o
brasil eu falo jovens imigrantes porque
na grande maioria é o jovem que não tem
aquela aquele compromisso dentro de casa
é um membro mais saudável da família é
homem e tem a disposição de deixar o seu
país a sua cultura o conforto de casa
para ser o primeiro daquele ambiente
familiar que se dispõe a ir para um país
e nós pinto como é o nesse caso o brasil
em 2013 eu me aproximo do desse grupo de
haitianos na cidade em 2014 o seu eleito
presidente do conselho municipal da
juventude onde um terço é de membros do
governo dois tentos da sociedade civil e
ali eu sou convidado pra discutir a
situação dos haitianos na cidade devido
à minha formação sou convidado pelo
secretário de segurança pública no
conselho municipal de segurança pública
com a presença de todo o secretariado
vereadores líderes e diretores e
presidentes de entidades e associações
de classe e eu quero ressaltar aqui esse
convite porque é o pelo secretário de
segurança pública pelo conselho
municipal porque no nosso imaginário o
jovem
ele é sempre uma ameaça e um imigrante
também é uma ameaça neste caso antes de
discutir a inclusão a gente foi discutir
a segurança e eu vou lá faça uma
apresentação de dez minutos
e no meio dessa apresentação eu sou
interrompido por um diretor de uma
entidade que promove intercâmbio
internacional e ele fala o seguinte eu
tenho um restaurante contratei dois
haitianos e eles trouxeram salmonela pro
meu restaurante eu parei apresentação e
só pensei então quer dizer que nunca
existe um salmonela no verão em
balneário camboriu antes da vinda dos
haitianos
depois eu comparo o fluxo migratório que
hoje um fluxo migratório permanente
esses 200 viraram 1.600 na cidade
eu resido uma população de 108 mil
habitantes de acordo com o último censo
do ibge
eu comparo o fluxo migratório que é
formado com os brasileiros que emigraram
para a região de boston nos anos 90 ea
resposta que eu tenho desse senhor é que
ele se levanta no meio da reunião olha
pra mim fala isso é um absurdo como você
pode comparar brasileiros e haitianos
por mim você pode colocar todos num
container ele mandou novamente para o
haiti
infelizmente a intervenção do resto do
resto dos presentes foi a foi de rechaçá
opinião deste senhor e representava ali
uma entidade
só que eu saí dali conseguinte
conseguinte a gente tem que fazer alguma
coisa e e eu acho que tem combater o
preconceito com a ação ea gente leva
isso o conselho municipal da juventude
se aproxima das associações dos
haitianos e percebe que eles têm algumas
prioridades essa prioridade envolve
saúde educação e trabalho
na saúde a gente organizou um domingo à
tarde esperando um corte um de 20 e
migrantes haitianos uma formação para
eles entender o nosso modelo de saúde
porque porque eles tenham acostumado com
o sistema onde o mesmo médico acompanha
desde a infância até a vida adulta
conhece a família conhece o histórico e
tomar café ali enquanto faz a consulta
nas casas
e eles não sabiam quando eles vão pra
emergência quando eles vão pro pro posto
de atendimento então a gente fez um tira
dúvidas com a tradução simultânea do
francês e do pi o luta quem ainda não
não dominava o idioma e nessa atividade
a gente teve mais 50 pessoas presentes
era para durar uma hora durou duas horas
e meia e no final eles fizeram fila para
agradecer a todos que estavam ali
presentes junto com a secretaria de
saúde
depois nós desenvolvemos algumas outras
atividades por exemplo trabalho foi
formada uma rede de apoio de entidades e
associações e um coordenador da união
dos jovens pastores evangélicos de
balneário camboriu e as igrejas tanto
católicas como evangélica tem feito um
trabalho incrível entrou em contato
comigo e mencionou um caso de um
haitiano que gostaria de conversar se a
gente poderia dar um apoio este ano
estava trabalhando na obra de um prédio
ele caiu do terceiro andar teve uma
fratura exposta no braço
o engenheiro-chefe levou ele até o
hospital
largou e dinamarca devolveu a carteira
de trabalho falou pra ele que ele não
tinha nenhum direito porque a carteira
ainda não estava assinada a carteira
tinha sido entregue há mais de dois
meses
e a gente sabe que ninguém aqui é leigo
você tem 48 horas para registrar
qualquer funcionário independente da
nacionalidade pode ser espanhol
português alemão brasileiro jamaicano
haitiano e ele me procurou ele não sabia
o que fazer estava desesperado mal
conseguia andar porque ele queria ele ia
poder ficar impossibilitado de trabalhar
etapa que nosso país nos próximos seis
meses e ele não conseguiria trabalhar ea
gente entrou em contato assim o
ministério público sindicato e uma rede
de associações foi verificado na obra
pelos fiscais que ele a obra só
empregava 20 anos pagava por dia e eles
não tinham nenhum equipamento de
segurança
nós inclusive começamos a receber
algumas chamadas de ameaça nos nossos
telefones e falando dessa situação e
desse trabalho que a gente estava
estimulando pessoas a ter direitos que
eles não tinham e isso foi é foi muito
resolver o problema é gratificante mas
ao mesmo tempo a gente percebe como
ainda tem muita coisa para fazer
e aí eu volto pro nosso o nosso momento
inicial da conversa aqui que eu peço
todos sempre se coloquem na perspectiva
do outro e tenta entender essas
diferenças porque apesar das diferenças
todos nós temos os meios os mesmos
anseios as mesmas preocupações e as
mesmas esperanças e que ações isoladas
caridade não é dignidade e que a
integração desses jovens emigrantes ela
vai depender de todo um esforço coletivo
e dessa rede de apoio que está sendo
formado existem limitações
elas são muitas a começar pela ausência
de políticas públicas migratórias no
brasil mas algo precisa ser feito e eu
gostaria de deixar a seguinte mensagem
que nós temos aqui jovens pessoas que
estão vindo de outro país e que eles têm
grandes perspectivas ea forma como nós
vamos fazer esse acolhimento vai definir
como eles vão seguir convivendo na nossa
sociedade porque eles fazem parte da
nossa sociedade e o brasil o exemplo
brasileiro pode servir para o resto do
mundo porque a gente tem verificado que
alguns países eles tratam a situação
como a construção de muros ea proibição
da entrada seria a resolução do problema
e eu conversando com esses imigrantes eu
garanto pra vocês não é um carimbo ou
não é uma folha um documento e vai
impedir as pessoas de buscarem uma vida
melhor de ter uma vida digna
então eu acredito que nós temos aqui
dois caminhos dois caminhos bem claros
integrar ou segregar eu espero que nós
obtemos pelo primeiro e eu pensei que eu
ia ter que viajar o mundo a ajudar e
contribuir para mudá lo mas eu fui
perceber que pessoas que vieram do mundo
em busca de uma vida melhor
passaram pelo meu caminho ea gente está
tentando mudar a vida dessas pessoas
obrigado